Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson, the fired Fox News
propagandist, has resurfaced for the first
time and made the first statement since his
firing.
We're going to look at it so only a couple
of minutes long.
The funniest part of it is Tucker dressed
himself up like he still has a job.
I don't know why I find that hilarious.
He's probably wearing shorts, which is fine.
But he at least at the top half of his body
shirt and tie suit jacket and the entire thing,
it's almost like he's doing a monologue at
the top of his show, except there's no show
because he's been fired.
So let's listen to what he had to say.
He doesn't really mention much about the firing
itself.
It's also funny knowing that he's doing this
from the multimillion dollar studio that he
put in his house in order to be able to do
Fox News shows from home.
It's all just endlessly funny.
But let's listen.
Really a profile in courage, Tucker Carlson's
first statement since the firing.
Here we go.
Speaker 2: Good evening.
It's Tucker Carlson.
One of the first things he.
Speaker 1: Even starts as if he's still on
Fox News.
It's so good.
Speaker 2: You realize when you step outside,
the noise for a few days is how many genuinely
nice people there are in this country, kind
of decent people, people who really care about
what's true, and a bunch of hilarious people.
Also a lot of those.
It's got to be the majority of population,
right?
Speaker 1: The majority of the population
is really, really funny, serious people.
Speaker 2: Also a lot of those, it's got to
be the majority of population even now.
So that's heartening.
The other thing you notice when you take a
little time off is how unbelievably stupid
most of the debates you see on television
are.
Speaker 1: Yes, but this is so funny.
He's been fired for three days and he wants
to act like the biggest critic of the way
that television is produced.
His network and his the programs he's been
on for for decades at this point, quite frankly,
are the reason why we don't get substantive
debates on for profit television.
We don't get substantive discussions.
It's because you've got to cram in a four
minute interview in between commercials and
Lindsey Graham crying about something like
he's the it's it's not an incorrect diagnosis,
but he's the one who caused the illness in
the first place to a great degree.
Speaker 2: They're completely irrelevant.
They mean nothing.
True.
In five years, we won't even remember that
we had them.
Trust me, as someone who's participated and
you at the same time, and this is the amazing
thing, the undeniably big topics, the ones
that will define our future, get virtually
no discussion at all.
That's true.
Speaker 1: But that applies to his own program.
Now, I guess now he's saying with the benefit
of hindsight, you know, I had no choice.
They had me over a barrel or whatever the
case may be.
It's all you've got to read between the lines.
But it's a guy who is responsible for the
status quo, pretending to take the moral high
ground like he's a victim of it.
Speaker 2: War.
Civil Liberties.
Emerging science.
Demographic change.
Corporate power.
Speaker 1: By the way, demographic change
means You remember when he said, Brown people
come in and make us dirtier and poorer.
That's what he's talking about and trying
to whitewash here for resources.
Speaker 2: When was the last time you heard
a legitimate debate about any of those issues?
It's been a long time.
Debates like that are not permitted in American
media.
Both political parties and their donors have
reached consensus on what benefits them.
And they actively collude to shut down any
conversation about it.
Suddenly, the United States looks very much
like a one party state.
Huh.
That's a depressing realization, but it's
not permanent.
Our current orthodoxies won't last.
They're brain dead.
Nobody actually believes them.
Hardly anyone's life is improved by them.
This moment is too inherently ridiculous to
continue, and so it won't.
The people in charge know this.
That's why they're hysterical and aggressive.
They're afraid.
They've given up persuasion.
They're resorting to force.
Speaker 1: Now, I want to make another point
here, and then we'll listen to the last 30
seconds without another interruption.
You as an informed consumer of media.
You know, people who listen to my show, it's
obviously a self-selected group.
It's not random people.
I know many of you, because you wrote to me
and you responded to my tweets about this
video.
Many of you are confused about what the hell
Tucker Carlson is talking about now.
In short, he's basically.
Without directly saying it.
He's saying that the Deep state unit party
that controls Democrats and Republicans has
silenced him because he wanted to talk about
the big issues of our time and nobody would
let him talk about it or whatever.
But understand that if you follow all of these
different conspiracies and ideas, if you're
confused by what the hell Tucker Carlson is
talking about.
Imagine his audience.
They don't have a clue what this is about.
They it's it's the exact type of thing Trump
does where he talks about things no one really
understands because he's deliberately either
he's either deliberately off obvious skating
or confused.
But it doesn't matter because it's a cult
that follows him.
Speaker 2: But it won't work.
When honest people say what's true calmly
and without embarrassment, they become powerful.
Whoa.
The same time the liars who've been trying
to silence them shrink and they become weaker
as the iron law of the universe.
True things prevail.
Speaker 1: Doesn't seem like it.
Where can you.
Speaker 2: Still find Americans saying true
things?
There aren't many places left, but there are
some.
And that's enough.
As long as you can hear the words.
There is hope.
See you soon.
There you go.
Speaker 1: So now you're saying what is that?
A statement about the firing?
It doesn't sound like it has anything to do
with the firing.
You have to read between the lines.
And so when you read between the lines and
he talks about the unit party that's really
in power, it's not Democrats or Republicans.
When he talks about there are great forces
that don't want us to have the serious conversations
we need to have.
A lot of what's in the media is stupid and
all these different things.
He's essentially saying Fox News is part of
the problem.
It's not about left, right.
There is like some kind of greater elite that
is in charge and controlling everything.
And they want to silence me and they want
to silence you and all of these sort of things.
So on the practical matters, what is Tucker
Carlson's most likely next stop up?
I think the most profitable thing would be
his own venture.
And hilariously, because of the text messages
that were released as a result of the Dominion
Voting Systems lawsuit, we know that one of
his former producers was actually engaged
in texting with him.
I believe it was a producer about, hey, you
know what?
If we like, start our own thing and we could
make this much from the podcast and we could
make this this much from the website and so
on and so forth, particularly at this point
in time, it seems to me that Tucker's most
profitable move long term would be to start
his own thing and control all of the revenue.
The easier thing, and I can tell you this
is someone who I you know, I'm running the
entire thing here and so on and so forth.
The easier thing, although maybe less profitable,
would be just to get hired by someone like
would Newsmax hire Tucker?
They probably would.
Would it be as profitable as if he built up
his own entity?
No.
But he wouldn't have to worry about any of
that logistical stuff.
And you could just talk to the camera and
get a paycheck.
So I don't know where he will end up, but
it does seem the most lucrative option would
be to launch his own thing.
He's got a lot of followers and people who
would just send, you know, people send up
billionaire Trump money because he says I
need money and they don't think twice about
it.
They will obviously send Tucker money as well.
So that's it.
Tucker, Tucker Carlson, you know, respectfully
getting dressed up as if he still has a show
and delivering a two minute monologue about
how I guess everybody else is bad and he's
good and he'll tell you the truth.
We will continue to follow the Tucker saga.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this.